foreign
this is just amazing footage it's just
so reminiscent of the first world war
trench warfare it's
um it's not the sort of fighting that
we'd expect in the 21st century at all
and and what Russia has done here is
trying to drag Ukraine into a frenzied
war of attrition
we've now got a one of the Russian
soldiers very close by hurling a grenade
and that must be within 50 meters
probably closer and you can only imagine
the fear of the of the soldiers and the
intensity of the fighting
foreign
[Music]
s that the West is helping Ukraine with
weapons high-tech Precision weapons is
because the end of the first world war
the the Allies just never wanted to have
faced this sort of warfare again and
therefore rather than just have soldiers
hurting themselves into bullets and
dying causing massive casualties if you
can use technology on the battlefield so
you're hitting the bridges the
ammunition dumps the tanks at distance
then actually reduce the enemy's will to
fight rather than actually having to
kill them on the battlefield
the life
here's another grenade being being
thrown you just don't see that in in one
this is very reminiscent of the first
world war so part of what the West is
trying to do with Ukraine is drag them
into the 21st century so that in this
David versus Goliath battle uh in fact
there's another huge explosion on the
side there that's not a grenade that
looks like artillery or maybe even
aircraft so this fighting is not just
about the soldiers we're looking at here
it's also a lot of other effects coming
to bear but the whole point of this is
that if you can use technology then you
avoid this sort of Highly attritional
War and what the West is trying to do is
that Ukraine is a much smaller Force
than Russia has available and therefore
if it gets dragged into this traditional
Warfare the bigger force will win the
Goliath will prevail over the David
Russia will prevail over Ukraine
it must be horrendous for the young men
and women on the battlefield there and
this is just brings into star heart
harsh reality just the the horrors in
the 20th century and now amazingly in
the 21st century